davos wissen wer der böse mann versteht
ja teilweise gar nicht hast du dir zum
teil technisch gar nicht verlaufen
richtig aber selber ich brauche meine
ich meine meine meine tasche gerade ich
kannst du gerne übersetzen oder
übersetzen ja was auf eine sekunde
ich hab mir mal aufgeschrieben weil
nicht dass die leute denken meine texte
sind sinnlos
ich hab mal notiert was verstehe ich das
auf war einst ganz lässig etwas verstehe
ich und das war folgendes ferrari sitzt
nase bricht bahnhof trifft kopf ab opfer
hau dich pusht [ __ ] luftkriegs
komfort tatort straße carlo habe ich
habe richtig verstanden kommt nicht vor
den straßen star straße international
fest
ich hab dich gehört international sind
ja okay okay ich hab ja nur verstanden
es ist schon klar aber so viele der
teilweise müssen weil der bsv ist auf
zigarren ist ja ok aber das heißt junge
bamboo sagt man wir uns kunden auch bei
den türken
zu einem typen so ein respektvolles
wissen wer da war mist haft jahre haft
der große bruder okay aber ist er dem
lambo ferrari sitzt ferrari sitzt frau
diana wie manni which also ich begreife
in saudi arabien maria riesch wissen wer
der bar wo ist aktion französisches
walker erfahrung hat enzym machtlos er
hatte jetzt mach bloß keine bewegung
alle kids auf türkisch als game of
tennis auto bewegung alex keiner hat
jetzt bevor ich komme und dir deine nase
bricht das richtig deutsch bevor ich
komme und die deine nase voll ich komme
und diana sektor
bevor ich kann dir deinen brief wissen
wer da war wo ist immer noch derselbe
zarkovic also immer noch der gleiche
gleich summe in den bahnhof trifft wie
er gerade nasen swift wir gerade namens
mit wissen wer da war wo ist mein ganzes
leben ist reinhauen dass es nicht klappt
nase trieft ist oder ein also rheiner
bahnhof ja alles okay und wozu haben die
leute sind halt auch unterwegs ist
monate auf jeden fall
text apa foto katja kopf hat ist was ist
so toll comcom total.com bot vollkontakt
aller umbach
was heißt alle augen buck sowie am bug
um wachsen film ok denn in einer
warnbarke kennt den bug der typ mit den
ellbogen der kämpferin dem schienbein
und so ok kentenich waren hollywood
streifen sollte oder lieber das echt
altkupfer modern combat front tag darum
bakom run homerun am rande von er ist
toll sein opfer des honda ist sagert
besonders honda street fighter places
ist okay honda ist sagte mandat wählen
konnte
du bist honda ist ja zum teil burg
seinem spiel sagard video kenn ich nicht
link von hinten
schau dich frontal sec hat also schau
dich frontal behindert
eine kur für schmitt geht was los zu
hören so kommen wieder wenn du
luftkriegs rossi im plus tokio die das
ist jetzt mehr so hessisch ja musik
nichts mit hollywood frankfurt bruder
bruder ja du kannst winkt schon ist ein
kampfsport und kunst sowie bruce lee
kommst du tunceli nun sind es meine
stadtbücherei osten der türkei von
gerard pique uhr die 62
das von der stadt wo ich herkomm bauten
die nummernschilder also in deutschland
mit den buchstaben und der türkei sind
es ja ok und bei uns unser tun sie alles
62 konstituierten schicken coole d-mark
nutzen was war das nach der 62 die
kinder freuen
die 62 wurde
ok ok turnhalle markt nun zum schluss
hatten den tatort ohne erholung ohne
meinen sohn okay oder
und du legst danach dort traumstraßen
motto tagesordnung
amina produkt das heißt ich schick dir
und riskierten schwarze porsche ist mit
dem markt 0 motors macht nun motor sind
sowie bei mercedes und porsche mit dem
markt nur motors vollgas monte carlo
trugen aller formula uno sowie acht
jahre barbie straßen star international
übliche kurdistan das heißt kurdistan 3
was heißt baby so lange lebe ja lange
liebe kurdistan ich mach's ob die bahn
ok locker zehn sätze gesagt japan ist es
sehr wahrscheinlich an meinen mangel
denn wirklich kennen wissen ja da sind
hübsch wörter drin alter dabei ist doch
schwer zu verstehen also viele sagen ja
ich verstehe kein tor
er solle das tue